let me go to kelsey from colorado kelsey
from colorado
welcome you are on the air david good to
speak with you again
likewise hey uh so
i was thinking about this um and i kind
of want to get your opinion i just
watched your video
on uh uh
conspiracy theorists and i thought it
was fascinating
and um while i don't
i i my personal kind of experience
with it is um with a friend who was
um conservative in 2016 but
has then switched now to libertarian
okay but
a conversation we had um march right
before everything shut down
um was conspiracies um
linked to um kind of the government with
how funding works um i know a lot of her
stuff with
states rights um with in terms of
libertarianism
went in there and um
especially and then when the pandemic
hit it became a
well we're getting microchips this is
you know we get a vaccine or
well the government just before to stay
in and
we have to be you know enclosed but you
know i'm gonna go partying
um yeah that sounds less libertarian
than conspiratorial to me
yeah and that's what i'm getting from it
and so i guess
my question is what way do you kind of
engage with somebody that
is like you know they can't claim to be
very libertarian like they go
to conference with like ron paul and
like you know
say all that but then they're spewing
all these other conspiracy theories
that necessarily correlate with each
other well the two things aren't
necessarily related things
you we have to deal with conspiracy
theorists the way we know we are best
able to deal with conspiracy theorists
which is ask them
about the sources of their information
ask them
how many people would have to be
involved in keeping that quiet for it to
work
ask them how they determine whether a
news source is trustworthy
follow their conspiracy through to its
logical conclusion whether they happen
to also claim to be libertarian or not
i'm not so sure that i even see it as
relevant
sure yeah that makes sense yeah i just
think it was um
i i find it fascinating because she
she's his friend has changed
their uh political affiliation but has
still kept some of the
kind of wacky things that you would see
on the right is what you're seeing now
so yeah i just found it find it very
interesting but uh
you know the other thing to keep in mind
is it i'm not saying libertarians don't
exist
they certainly do but there's a lot of
people who claim to be libertarians or
to claim
or claim to be libertarian or
liberty-minded conservatives
who will very quickly become
extraordinarily authoritarian
when they see that the libertarian path
leads to things they don't like and so a
lot of these libertarians aren't even
really libertarians and so i i think
it's al
always import when someone has a
libertarian awakening some people really
do but some people don't they just found
a label that they prefer while still
being very authoritarian
that that makes sense cool well thanks
david i really appreciate your time
all right thank you kelsey from colorado
great to speak with you again
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book
or audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off
a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video